ATTEND IF IT DOES INDEED HAPPEN
TOMORROW.
THE BACKUP DATE OF THE LAUNCH IS
THE SATURDAY AND WE WILL BE
WATCHING.
>> Ed: OVERCROWDING AT POOL
PARTIES AND BEACH IS SPARKING
SOME CONTROVERSY IN MISSOURI.
ONE MISSOURI MARY SAYS PEOPLE
NOT TAKING PRECAUTIONS WILL HAVE
TO POLICE THEMSELVES.
>> THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF IMAGE
THAT I THINK WE WANT TO BE
PROJECTING AT LEAST FROM A
PANDEMIC GUIDELINE ENFORCEMENT
STANDPOINT.
WHEN I SAY AGAIN ENFORCEMENT,
NOT IS A TWO EDGE SWORD.
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY I
BELIEVE OF OUR GUESTS WHO ARE
DOWN HERE AND COME DOWN HERE.
>> Ed: IT WAS SPRING DR. MIKE
SIEGEL, PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT
NYU LANGONE.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING ED.
>> WITH THAT MARE SAYING
SOMETHING YOU HAVE SAID BEFORE
IS THAT WE ESSENTIALLY HAVE TO
TREAT ADULTS LIKE ADULTS, BUT
WHEN YOU SEE SOME OF THESE
PICTURES WHEN ADULTS ARE NOT
BEHAVING WELL ESSENTIALLY AND
NOT SOCIAL DISTANCING, HOW
CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT PLACES
LIKE THE OZARKS AND OTHERS WHERE
WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT?
>> I AM VERY DISTURBED ABOUT
THIS, THOSE PICTURES OVER THE
WEEKEND, LAKE OF THE OZARK IS
ABOUT DRIVING DISTANCE FROM
ST. LOUIS AND KANSAS CITY AND
THEN YOU HAVE FLORIDA, TAMPA HAD
A PARKING LOT TO BE CLOSED
BECAUSE THERE WAS SO MANY PEOPLE
MILLING AROUND THE EAST COAST OF
FLORIDA.
ALL THREE OF THE STATES I
MENTIONED HAVE FLATTENED THE
CURVE BUT IF YOU SEE THIS KIND
OF CAVORTING GOING ON GOING ON,
THERE’S A SYMPTOMATIC SPREAD OF
COVID-19 AND WE DON’T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW IT SPREADS BUT CLOSE
CONTACT WILL DEFINITELY SPREAD
IT.
DR. DEBORAH BIRX AT TASK FORCE
SAID IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE
CLOSE TOGETHER OR AT LEAST WEAR
A MASK.
I WOULD WITH ALL DUE IN RESPECT
TEND TO DISAGREE WITH THAT
SLIGHTLY BECAUSE I DON’T THINK
THE MASKED AS NEARLY AS MUCH A
SOCIAL DISTANCING DOES.
IT SEVERAL FEET THAT THE COUGH
OR SNEEZE CAN TRAVEL AND WE WILL
END UP HAVING TROUBLE IF WE
REOPEN.
MISSOURI IS SAYING SOME OF THE
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING IT, MAYBE
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD GO INTO
QUARANTINE AFTER THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR AND I’M NOT AGAINST
THAT.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
>> Ed: AND JUST A SUMMER IS
STARTING, THE UNOFFICIAL START
OF SUMMER COURSES MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND, WE WILL HAVE TO LISTEN
TO GOOD ADVICE FROM YOU KNOW
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I WANT TO GET SOMETHING ELSE
THAT’S MORE OPTIMISTIC WHICH IS
WE ARE -- THEY HAVE A TRIAL NOVA
VAX, AND THAT’S PART OF THE
REASON WHY THE DIE WAS POPPING
THIS MORNING.
PHASE ONE BEGINS IN AUSTRALIA
WITH 130 PARTICIPANTS BETWEEN
THE AGES OF 18-39 AND THE TRIAL
WILL TEST TUBE DOSAGES BOTH WITH
AND WITHOUT NECK VACCINE.
IF IT’S SUCCESSFUL PHASE TWO
WOULD INCLUDE U.S. AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WALK US THROUGH WHERE YOU SEE
SOME GOOD THINGS HERE AND WHERE
YOU HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
>> I’M ACTUALLY VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS THE TENTH CANDIDATE
WHICH WILL EMPLOY INTO CLINICAL
AND THIS IS INTERESTING,
DR. FAUCI CALLED THIS SHOTS ON
GOAL.
THIS PARTICULAR VACCINE IS USING
INSECTS YET TO GROWTH OF
PROTEINS THAT ARE LIKE THE VIRUS
TO PROVOKE YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM.
WE TALKED ABOUT MODERNITY AND
THE PFIZER VACCINES TALKING
ABOUT GENETIC TERMINOLOGY TO
START YOURSELVES WITH THOSE
PROTEINS THAT CAUSE THE IMMUNE
RESPONSE.
THE ONE OUT OF OXFORD UNIVERSITY
USE A LITTLE OLDER TECHNOLOGY
AND THE NEWER ONES THEY ACTUALLY
PROVOKE MORE OF A ROBUST
RESPONSE.
ONE THING IS FOR SURE, WITH ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT VACCINE
CANDIDATES PROCEEDING SO RAPIDLY
IN THE CLINICAL TRIALS, I’M
OPTIMISTIC WITH THE
MANUFACTURING BEING SET UP TO
KEEP PACE WITH THIS, TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE SCIENCE, THAT WE
MAY END UP WITH THE VACCINE BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR OR EARLY
NEXT YEAR.
IT’S REALLY LOOKING GOOD RIGHT
NOW.
NEVER BEEN DONE THIS WAY.